and these feminists cornered me with my
back against the wall prepped Lisa
spitting in my face and said aren't
aren't nothing that demeans women can be
art now how can you have any as a
student of art history how could anyone
have any dialog of people who have such
a what is that that is the that is the
Nazi and Stalinist view of art okay
where where art is subordinate to up to
a prefab political agenda I am Nick
Gillespie with Reason TV and today we're
talking with Camille Polly she's a
cultural critic and art critic a
literature critic a teacher at
University the Arts in Philadelphia
where we're filming as she's best known
as the author of sexual persona a great
book that came out in 1990 more recent
work includes break blow burn of reading
of 43 of the world's best poems from
2005 and glittering images a journey
through art from Egypt to star wars in
2012 Camille thanks for talking to you
let's talk about the contemporary state
or the state of contemporary feminism
you have been at you know in a public
life or in an intellectual life since
the late 60s a proud feminist often
reviled by other feminists Gloria
Steinem I guess most famously said that
you were an anti-feminist and then when
you denied that that would be like she
said a Nazi saying they're not
anti-semitic you're mixing it up what is
going on with the state of kind of
professional feminism in this country it
seems if you look at from say the early
70s or whatever benchmark you want to
look at things have gotten better for
women men are less uptight about gender
roles women are more in the work force
they get paid equally sexual assault and
sexual violence are down in so many ways
things are going better than ever and
yet from you know sites like Jezebel are
Feministing all you hear is that things
have never been worse
well feminism has gone through in many
phases and absolutely the woman suffrage
movement of the 19th century fizzled
after women gained the right to vote
through the constitutional amendment in
1920 and then the movement revived in
the late 1960s through Betty Friedan
okay co-founding now in 1967 and now I
proceeded all that I'm on record and the
letter in Newsweek I was in high school
1963 where I called for equal rights in
uniform for American women and so on I
began thinking about gender and
researching it I loved the generation of
Amelia Earhart and all those emancipated
women of the 20s and 30s and so I
because I had started my process of
thought about gender so much earlier I
was out of sync with with the women's
movement when it when it suddenly burst
forth talk a little bit about what it
was like to grow up I mean you were
living in upstate New York I was your
sexuality did you already know what your
sexuality was but what was it like to be
a woman what was it like to be a lesbian
in 1963 well in 1950s were a highly
conformist period where it was the
gender had repolarized after after
really great gains it seems to me in the
20s and 30s and the reason for that has
one must be more sympathetic to Lee to
the you know the situation of my parents
generation they had no nothing but
depression and war throughout their
entire lives my everyone returned from
from the Army my father got out of you
know he was a paratrooper got out of the
army everyone married and I'm the baby
boom okay the you know part of that
generation that was the result of that
they wanted normality they just want to
live like like real people man and wife
in a home I found the 1950s utterly
suffocating I was I was a young gender
non-conforming entity right and I was
signaling my my rebellion by these
transgender Halloween costumes they were
absolutely unheard of I was like five
six seven and eight my parents allowed
me to do it because I was I was what
were you dressing up those Roman soldier
the Matador from Carmen my best was
Napoleon I was Hamlet from the classics
Comics book and so and I absolutely no
one was anything like this I so um and
I'm I'm happy that this that this talk
about sex in medical sex changes in the
surgical sex injure was not in the air
because I would have become obsessed
with that and assume that that was my
entire identity and problem so this is
why I am very concerned about the rush
to surgical interventions today so any
rate you know by time by the time I had
any consciousness of being a
I mean I was attracted to men III dated
men but I just fell in love with women
have always have okay so yes there's
absolutely no doubt I was on the
forefront of gay identification when I
arrived in graduate school at Yale 1968
to 72 I was the only openly gay person
at the Yale graduate school I didn't
even have a sex life okay IIT was a
badge of militants so and I was the only
person doing a dissertation on a sexual
topic it's hard to believe this now what
what was the sexual persona anyway okay
yeah book which finally got published
1890 after being rejected by seven
publishers and five agents I'm delighted
I had the sponsorship of Harold Bloom
that push the the topic through the
English department I think possibly you
know that they allowed me to do such a
thing on sex was it was I'm actually
kind of well welcome back to him because
I think he's one of the villains of the
current culture oh yeah so but anyway
all my clashes with with other feminists
began immediately okay because for
example there was it like was only 1970
I believe it was or 71 there was a
feminist conference at the Yale Law
School
okay and and the major feminists were
there including Rita Mae brown who said
to me that you know the difference
between you and me Camille is that you
want to save the universities and I want
to burn them down okay this is what okay
all right I mean how can you have
dialogue with these people okay the
leadership became a rich lesbian
novelist and they has the horse farm of
Virginia all right and then I had a
screaming fight okay with a New Haven
women's liberation rock band over over
over the Rolling Stones because at that
time hard rock was defined as sexist now
this argument seemed so retrograde now
although it's true I've been the put the
guitar is a phallus the rock god is
Dionysius he's not he's not a woman
but at that time there were no women
musicians that's why it was my Patty
Smyth wasn't with interest was so
radical when she you know Frank Sinatra
garb for me before on the front of
horses but I mean we had the screaming
fight about under my thumb okay the song
and I said yes yes the lyrics under my
thumb are sexist but this is song is a
great song this is a this is this is a
work of art and so on and these
feminists cornered me with my back
against the wall proudly spitting in my
face and said art art nothing that
demeans women can be art now how can you
have any as a student of art history how
could anyone have any dialogue with
people who have such a what is that that
is the that is the Nazi and Stalinist
view of art okay where art is
subordinate to a to a prefab political
agenda okay next what's the argument
over hormones okay again screaming
argument over hormones when I was told
by the founding members of the Women's
Studies department in the city diversity
of New York at Albany that I had been
brainwashed by male scientists to
believe that hormones even existed much
less had any role in the shaping of our
identity in our character okay so I was
banned from the women's movement from
the start but i reaiiy kept going on my
i wa i was pro pornography
pro prostitution gang libertarian
grounds later Dovie award for this and
so on for years finally my wing of
feminism which had been silenced all
that time we were silenced and
ostracized by the Steinem wing okay they
establishment wing partisans of the
Democratic Party my party but
nevertheless I don't really feel that
feminism should have been subordinated
to any party okay all right finally we
rose okay in the 90s and by the pro-sex
wing of feminism one in the 90s thanks
to Madonna having changed okay stop for
a second let's define what it for you
what is the essence of feminism is it
using the lens of gender to explore
every given issue or is it a set of
political positions that can't trade
well my view I am an equal opportunity
feminist okay I believe that all
barriers to women's advance in the
social political realm must be removed
however I do not feel that gender okay
is sufficient to explain all of human
life okay
this is the gender myopia the gender
monomania okay has become a diseases we
know a substitute for a religion okay so
because we have a whole cosmic view that
it is impossible okay
that that feminists the feminist agenda
can ever be the total explanation for
human life this is our problem now okay
is that is this this this monomania
identity politics in the 1970s so people
see everything through the to the lens
of race or gender or social class this
is a madness an absolute madness and in
fact it's a distortion of the 60s okay I
was a distortion and and you're not
saying that those things race class and
gender which is kind of the holy trilogy
Holy Trinity of contemporary cultural
studies but all of those things are
important and they all intersect in many
ways but you're you're essentially
arguing that it's not a none of these
are none of these explain things total
that's right that's right
these are techniques of social analysis
I find very useful I that's the way I
teach the way I write and all this I'll
race class and gender absolutely okay so
talk about but the point is these aren't
there Marxism okay yes I argue in the
introduction to my last book littering
images is not sufficient as a
metaphysical system for explaining the
cosmos okay it is very limited Marxism
sees only society but we are much
greater than that okay there's nature
there's eternity there's you know
there's more questions of mortality
which Catholic theology of the Middle
Ages addressed far more profoundly the
Marxism ever and of course I mean one of
the foundational texts I guess is its
second wave feminism the dialectic of
sex by show loveth Firestone literally
just took a class out of the Marxist
nails and put in gender and that did the
same thing and so that so you're saying
I mean there's some power in those moves
but they're limited yes that's right
these are simply tools there are tools
okay but we should have we should have a
large toolbox right wait is that the
less is that the lesbian you talking do
you want a large tool bar no I it's
actually ex-catholic okay I'm an atheist
okay but but there's no doubt that I see
things theologically and I was I was
profoundly influenced by Hinduism and
Buddhism when I was in college at the
Harper College upstate New York
I think these ideas were everywhere I
feel that the 60s had a vision enlarged
cosmic perspective that was absolutely
lost in this in this degeneration okay
in this splintering of the 1979 one
Chile's into this identity politics what
drove that was it you know was it just
that the revolution needs a don't eats
its own or is that there was a shrinking
economic pie so people started you know
grabbing for whatever they could before
the Titanic went down what what explains
kind of the you know narrowing of a
cosmic vision into something my
explanation I actually wrote an entire
essay okay about about the religious
vision of the of the American 1960s
this is an ethical cult and Cosmic
Consciousness and I feel okay it had the
real visionary thinkers of my generation
destroyed their brains on on drugs okay
I think LSD just every level alright I
think this this this conversation is
over okay good
now I'm yeah so you say I mean it was
who were who are the people who
destroyed themselves on my classmates
every people they I think the authentic
Ahmet imaginations though the really
innovative people of my generation that
did the most daring okay of my of my
generation took the drug now I for some
reason okay felt that the LCD was
untested and I did not want to
experiment with it and by I was but I
was very interested in I was interested
in all such a Vision Quest
you know things at the time I went up
with my fellow students to see Timothy
Leary speaking Cornell I saw him and in
it made me uneasy there was that he was
the Guru there was like such a such a
crowd around him he was such a magnetic
but his face was already twitching I
could see I said I said this is not
going to end well and it did not okay so
if when I got to graduate school in 1968
okay I can attest to the fact that no
authentically radical student of the
1960s ever went to graduate school so
all that were left with the time servers
hoo-hoo-hoo-hoo parasitically battened
on the achievements of the 60s i can for
heaven's sake
when is it here's an example when I was
in when I I was applied to graduate
schools I applied to six or seven
graduate schools and I knew didn't get
into the one you wanted so you weren't
yeah well I I and I wanted to made the
choice for Yale because of the library I
felt that I needed to live in this
research library but listen I but I also
applied to Buffalo and I thought I'm
going to Buffalo Leslie Fiedler was
there Norman Holland was there okay so I
could easily gone to Buffalo at any rate
okay I was confronted by the leader of
the campus radicals on the quad okay
said I heard you're going to Yale he's
any you don't do that in graduate school
that's not where it's happening okay he
he he did allow that if I were to go -
go / - go to Buffalo okay there was only
thing he permitted okay so on okay
but this these people okay the idea that
there were any tenure
radicals is Roger Campbell's Facebook
this is this is not true there was that
the only time you know give it he's the
only one and Todd Gitlin who was the
leader of students for a Democratic
Society yes so yeah I mean there weren't
any radicals that were tenure
bureaucrats or apparatchik so you're not
so here's here's the thing okay any
authentic leftist okay who had a job at
a university in 1970s or 80s or 90s
should have been opposing the entire
evolution okay of the universities okay
that is toward this in this
administrative bureaucracy that has
totally robbed power from the faculty
okay the total speciousness and fraud of
academic leftism is proved by the
passivity of these people in every
department of the university to that
power play that happened now my first
job in bennington we rose up in 1976 we
rose the faculty gave voted no
confidence in the president into in to
fight back against the board okay we
rejected the power of the board okay and
where has there ever been after that you
see any such uprising well two questions
one is that I you know I actually think
you're right that universities travel on
their faculty and the faculty you know
various studies have shown that there
has not been a growth in the number of
faculty certainly not of tenure-track
faculty but the big growth in employment
in universities is in administration
solutely and whatnot but a laries if you
went to college up through about the
mid-80s and and certainly from the late
60s through about the mid 80s there was
no in loco parentis you know there were
fewer and fewer required courses it was
a kind of temporary autonomous zone then
it's sort of getting ratcheted down and
now when you hear about the student
experience it's about required courses
and it's about you know making people
think certain things or not express
certain things and it's so much of the
focus of undergraduate education seems
to be on kind of indoctrinating people
into the proper ways of thinking how
does that play into this passivity on
the part of the faculty I mean is it
that the faculty wants to see that
happen and so they're happy to have
bureaucrats Rob all I can say is that
once again the that the people who went
into teaching okay
and went to graduate school okay which
are just followers a sheep as far as I'm
concerned okay let me just hit somebody
in loco parentis okay because when I
arrived in college 96 before the in loco
parentis was was operative I was in a
girl's dorm we had a sign in at 11
o'clock at night the boys could run free
they had panty raids who would like
people threw water at them you know I
thought the windows and so on we are the
one my generation of women rose up and
said he said get out of our you know of
our private lives and the university
said no the world is dangerous we must
protect you against rape against attack
all these all those things and we said
yes freedom yeah what freedom risk rate
that is the true freedom isn't it true
though that what they were trying to
restrain was not rape but rather your
sexual your sexual appetite uh well I
think that they believe they were acting
for the parents okay there was their
obligation to protect and so now
everything in that this is why I what I
went out so much against the grain of
contemporary feminists and when I
started when I wrote about the date rape
you know of hysteria okay I wrote this
inflammatory piece and for Newsday 1991
that is that's still I'm still being
persecuted about any everywhere people
are slot angry about it and basically
what I said was when a free women must
take personal responsibility for their
own sex lives okay and then they keep
authority figures out and and to be
clear in no way is this sanctioning
sexual violence what you're talking
about our cases where people retro
actively reclassify something of
regrettable sexual experience that they
would rather have not consented to I'm
talking about date rape okay widget
which is what everyone is talking about
and right now okay about the so-called
rape culture okay my that essay that I
wrote begins
rape is an outrage that cannot be
tolerated any similar society that's not
what I'm talking about I'm talking about
this new reclassification okay of people
getting drunk you're going on a date
going to fraternity houses and women not
taking responsibility for their own
behavior okay I said a gay man for
thousands of years have been going out
and having sex with strangers everywhere
they know they can be beaten up they
know they can be killed
okay what what is this with women are
like oh we must be protected against the
even even our foolish choices okay
it's up to men today what this is this
is ridiculous this is
an intrusion okay it into okay the the
Civil Liberties of young people to have
this kind of this kind of vampiric
parent figures in the administrators
hovering over watching aren't watching
will supervising people sex life in
Europe there's nothing like this okay
people there's no idea that the
University of Paris is concerned about
the dating lives of the damsel they also
they don't have sports teams and they
don't have dorm right exactly it is
residential college thing okay this is
this vision of college if summer camp is
Club Med that's that this is this is the
fun it's actually it's more it's more
re-education camp now right so it can't
flow to a job rather than let us give
you the incredible gym with the exercise
equipment let's give you the thousand
choices in the cafeteria this is not
going to do with education anymore okay
ml education okay is being committed
from coast to coast in the United States
talk a little bit about Madonna's effect
on the culture which we're still feeling
I mean one of the most interesting
things and I've talked to people about
this like before and after Madonna every
Hollywood movie I mean it is in many
popular novels that many artistic novels
have you know it's all about virgin
[ __ ] you know a woman can only be a
virgin or a [ __ ]
Madonna obviously played with that and
in her wake it just seems like virgin
[ __ ] complex which bedeviled you know
Western civilization for centuries it it
doesn't really seem to matter anymore
well Madonna's great period was 1983 to
1992 okay she'll absolutely changed the
world okay there's no doubt about it and
since then it's like it's cringe making
and when the current Madonna I mean it's
embarrassing I think you will agree that
when she started faking the English
accent Madonna the real Madonna's died
every bit as much as Elvis died when he
went into the York but when Madonna did
okay is to allow a young women okay to
flirt with men to to seduce men to
control men okay she showed that you
could be sexy but the same time control
the the negotiations control the you
know the territory between male and
female and that was it was really
powerful
okay very powerfully and so now we're in
a period I mean I do I don't understand
okay
we're we have some of that word now you
know the women on campus the the
whinings institutionalized whining now
okay about it that that's what it's
turned into here clarify what's the
difference between the
legitimate gripe and and and whining
well in my point of view okay
no college administration okay should be
taking taking any interest would ever
okay in the social lives of the students
none okay if a crime is committed on
campus it should always have been
reported to the police
absolutely not agree by any committees
investigating any charge of sexual
assault okay either either it's a real
crime or it's not a real crime get the
hell out okay and so on so you'll get
this the expansion of the campus
bureaucracy okay with this absolutely
Stalinists okay oversight in my
christine in the students i have been
raised with helicopter parents they want
it the students of today okay are there
ugly unformed and not necessarily in my
school there art school I'm talking
about the elite schools so it's those
kids over at that other school it's the
grade grubbers if the grade grubber sub
right over achievers I'm not at that
kind of school okay I'm at a school of
arts and communication okay we're poor
people already have a vocational trends
okay to be admitted here you have to
already have a vocational aptitude okay
but I'm talking about you know the ID
the Ivy League now I'm encountering
these graduates okay of harvard yale
university of pennsylvania princeton i
encounter them in the media okay and i
can people in their 30s now some of them
okay their minds are like jello they
know nothing they've not been trained in
history k they have absolutely no
structure to their minds they like their
emotions are unfixed okay so it's in the
banality of contemporary cultural
criticism okay of a khadeem okay the
absolute collapse okay of any kind of of
intellectual discourse in the u.s. is
the result of these colleges okay we
should have been defined the best okay
and have produced the finest minds
instead having retracted into caretaking
the whole thing is about approved social
positions and in a kind of misty love of
humanity okay without any direct
knowledge okay of his history or
economics or apology you know uh maybe
the university is not the place where
that sort of stuff is happening anymore
so for instance you have think tanks
that do a lot of economic or policy work
you have popular historians who are not
academic you know are not academic I
mean fiction and poetry
even as there's been a rise of a kind of
you know for decades now creative
creative writing programs and whatnot
nobody looks to the University to be
cutting edge on you know on almost
anything really so maybe it's just that
you picked the wrong maybe you should
have followed the campus radicals
you know suggestion and got not gone
into academic I mean that you know I in
terms of as a writer of cultural
criticism okay you know I find that I'm
happiest when I'm writing for let's say
the British press you know I write it
quite a bit for the Sunday Times
Magazine in in London and I find that
the general sense of cultural awareness
okay that can have an authentic
discourse about ideas okay with
international journalists okay from
Brazil or Germany or Italy or Norway
okay are Canada even some whatever they
there's what they have a pretty problem
themselves but but you know I I can feel
okay the vacuum okay and then the
nothingness okay of American cultural
criticism at the present time is
impossible and is that is any journalist
of today an American journalist you
cannot have any kinds of a deep deep
discussion is that just a kind of hyper
exaggeration of the American disease
which is that we've never and I mean
this goes back to you know early
American literature literary criticism
that were you know where people who come
from nowhere and we don't care about the
past where we're freed from the burdens
of the past but we don't care about yes
yes
I think this is true the prep that the
past is always present day in year up to
the extent that you're in Berlin you can
see the bullet marks still on the
buildings from World War two and so on
it's a terrible burden okay to have that
there okay I think Americans are far
more ingenious and open and daring okay
on the other hand you know the nature of
our politics to the way we have we keep
on having this there's like the two big
parties with their big tent and they're
there their internal gradations you know
of affiliation whereas people abroad
okay have it have a much more
sophisticated idea about about your
person's specific intellectual and
political positions they can identify
you know because they'll have 13 parties
you know conflicting in Parliament and
so on
so I think that's been a problem over
here is that it's either either-or okay
you're either a liberal or conservative
and watch your like your watch you're
combining things from
both sides and then obviously you're a
traitor against one it's like it's
becoming like a subsidy for religion
when you're a Democrat or Republican
over here okay and there was a period
where I felt there was a as that you had
the first conservative challenge coming
from talk radio okay - in the early 90s
- the liberal hegemony in the made in
the mainstream you know I thought it was
a very exciting period cuz you start to
get the clash of ideas but now you know
now on the right itself is become a
victim of its own insularity and I want
to feel that dialogue anymore
you did not exist as you were talking
about in the mid-60s so your subject
your your cultural identity did not
exist and now you are you know there's a
million types of people that you could
be you can be a conservative lesbian you
can be you know you can be out you know
polyamorous you can be bisexual you me
this you can be that there's been I mean
would you agree that there's been a just
massive proliferation of legitimate
cultural identities that are out there
and is that a good thing or a bad thing
and what's driving what's driving that
move forward well you know first I was
very excited about you know the ethnic
identity movement because I feel very
italian-american and I've always been in
revolt against the so the wasp style
that dominated a khadeem when I first
elizy if you look Fiedler himself was a
victim of this I think Harold Bloom was
and I mean they weren't even any Jews
hired in the Yale English department -
like the mid-1950s and there was there
were quotas and Jewish students admitted
to Harvard me all things like that but
it but you know over time okay what's
what's happened - I think okay that that
gender identity has become really almost
fascist okay and it's to me a very
shrunken miniaturized way of perceiving
your position in the world and in the
universe okay there was a time when you
know these are at least now these fine
gradations of gender identity okay I'm
on male trans doing this with you know
with that going move that this this is a
symptom of decadence I'm sorry as in my
sexual persona he talks about it that
was that was in fact the the inspiration
of sexual persona was that my overview
of history and in my in my noticing that
it in
eight phases use all of a sudden get a
proliferation of homosexuality of
sadomasochism okay of gender games and
impersonations and masks and so on so I
like face we're late phase so so that
the proliferation of cultural identities
the proliferation of all sorts of
possibilities is actually a sign that
were under collapse on yo yes Western
culture is in is in decline
there's absolutely this absolute no
doubt about it okay they might in my
view okay as looking at the history of
Egypt of Babylon okay you know Rome yeah
okay and so on did axis and so what's
happening is the busy everyone's so busy
busy busy okay with themselves and with
the sob cystic you know narcissistic you
know a sense of who they are in terms of
sexual orientation or gender and in this
intense gender consciousness women
consciousness at the same time and
meanwhile is that also racial
consciousness or ethnic well I think
that I think right now I kidded to me
that the real obsessions have to do with
gender orientation about although I
think there's been this flare-up I I
voted for Obama okay but I have been
bitterly disappointed I think we had
hoped that he would inaugurate a period
of racial harmony and I think it's
actually the situation has become even
worse okay over the panel for recent
years with it seems to me overt in
phlegm you know inflammatory actions by
the administration and to to pit the
races against each other in the in the
US so I think it's a lot of damage that
needs to be healed but I I think I think
most of the problems is I perceive them
okay I mean it's like I can see them in
my students and so on is that there is a
new obsession okay with where you are on
this on this wide gender spectrum okay
and in a view of gender that seems to me
it seems to me unrealistic because it is
so divorced or any kind of biological
referent me I do believe in biology I do
believe in an occult I say the first
first paragraph of section or Sony that
sexuality is an intricate intersection
of nature and culture but what's
happened now is that the way the
universities are teaching is nothing but
culture okay and it's not nothing's from
biology it's madness it's a form of
madness okay because women who want to
marry and have children okay I going to
have to encounter there
our moral reality is a certain point
okay but I mean so do you see your
personal liberation was you know that
helped grease the skids for decadence or
for the end the collapse of Western
civilization I have yes do you feel at
all ambivalent about that I've defined
myself as a decadent okay my Vic when my
first influences was Oscar Wilde I
stumbled on a little book called the
epigrams of Oscar Wilde in a secondhand
bookstore in Syracuse New York and I was
like 14 right and I was fascinated by
his statement so I am a wild and as I'm
saying and he identified himself as like
as a kind of decadent right that period
of asceticism and and certainly he was
towards the end of the great hegemony of
England as a world power as a culture
officer - yes the decline of the Empire
absolutely absolutely right so you know
somebody like Leslie Fiedler who taught
for years at Buffalo and before that
University of Montana he wrote about
freaks he wrote about you know he did
not seem to see it as a as a sign of
decadence though it wasn't a kind of a
delivery on you know the promise of an
America where you could be an individual
and where you could kind of create new
forms of existence and new forms of
identity well to me Fiedler was one of
the myth critics okay there was a whole
beauty north of Frey right you know was
a huge influence on me and these the
myth critics had this enormous view of
history and of culture and it's probably
influenced by young okay yeah I mean
we're talking arch types here of yes yes
this kind of syncretism room is seeing
all the religions of the world all the
cultures of the world and so that broad
vision to me is the authentic
multiculturalism and Leslie Fiedler had
it there's the formula okay he honored
also the great writers so he's someone
he worked in Chaucer from say he worked
in John Donne okay all right didn't have
any any any fetish about you know the
dead white European male he understood
them of the vitality has switched over
to America I but he but he was he was a
Liveris my own concerns have changed and
they Center in a place where you know on
a topic which I think everybody has to
worry about now which is the
relationship between what we've come to
call high culture and popular culture
and what I'm interested in doing is
blowing up
that distinction completely the people
today have it what they practice New
Historicism it's like it's such a I call
you just yuppie buffet-style we take it
a little here a little this a little
this you juxtapose them you make cutesy
remarks and that's it I think there's no
deep learning any longer okay well yeah
let's talk about that and particular
style yeah the Jewish style of Fiedler
or of Harold Bloom it's deep ere you
edition well here's here's something
interesting the movie version of Fifty
Shades of Grey yes
okay it has been accused and valorized
for introduced you know mainstreaming
BDSM it is always remarked upon as this
is sub literary it's you know it you
take ein Rand and you dumb her down and
you're still like a mile above where al
James is Fiedler in particular and this
seems very distinct from somebody like
Harold Bloom he was famous for talking
about the effect that Tex had on
audiences you know so that gone with the
wind which was you know you know just
dismissed by real critics as Chiclets
and you know it's not really literature
it's certainly no Faulkner it tells us
nothing about the South etc and Fiedler
said no actually you need to look at a
book that makes you cry every time you
read it which is what he would say and
that has a hold on millions of people is
meaningful how does that square with I
mean you know and obviously sexual
percenter very much like a book like
love and death in the American novel is
this incredible work where you're
grabbing from high and low you're
talking about the ancient I mean it's an
incredibly learning book how do you
square great poem like high and low
great but the point is I call for
standards but I but I take popular cut
for me it's the great art but also
popular culture but within those feels
ok I think this is good this is not good
so I find I don't think that is any
difference okay for me it ruined the
Fiedler way okay I mean I respond to
both I always respond to the both okay
great art okay and also Elizabeth Taylor
okay so on at a time when she wasn't
taken seriously and I always follow my
instincts and and and a pleasure
principle what would be a way forward
for colleges or other institutions to
start you know kind of making a defense
of the humanities I guess is what I'm
asking how do you you know you you oh
that's how bless yeah
absolutely ho plus the humanities
destroyed themselves with that veering
toward post modernist and postdoctural
ISM it's over okay they said they have
been completely marginalized okay good
night
deconstruction bye-bye you know by
questioning and you know undermining and
throwing out the whole idea of the of
the you know of the genius of the of the
master of great works of art you know I
believe that there are great works of
art I do not I do not believe okay that
the Canon is produced by critics sitting
in a room to to intensify their own
power
I believe the Canon is created by other
artists okay you indentify the Canon by
who had the greatest influence on other
artists over time okay that is that is
the story but about the whole historical
tradition the linear line in which I
believe in absolutely believed in in
terms of art history has been discarded
okay the survey courses are being
abandoned okay the graduate students are
not being trained even to think in large
terms anymore they have no sense of
history okay but I find there's more
sense of history okay in in southern
evangelicals who didn't even finish high
school okay because there's their
knowledge of the world is based on the
Bible right so they're thinking in terms
of what happened 2,000 years ago
what happened 2,500 years ago you think
it's impossible to revivify the the
humanities I how how's it going to
happen well I'm asking you and you're
making a pretty good case that it I like
it so I figure I want parents to rebel
and stop paying these these obscene
prices okay I want the gut you know that
the government is like you know put all
that loan money flush into the college
and drove up the tuition obscenely and
said okay I want to return to vocational
education okay right I mean when you get
okay with people now being trained for
real jobs where where then do people
talk about ideas you're not going to get
in history is forces the universities to
pare down this ridiculously overinflated
curriculum to what is necessary now what
some I had a very wonderful experience
when I was finishing sexual persona
living in New Haven in the early 1980s
and I was teaching for these just
refreshment courses you know of a
literature course is basic you know
great books courses to to night classes
at the Sikorsky helicopter
after refectory okay these are adults
okay who are married with children or
the many of that some of them were
middle-aged okay just getting additional
credits all right so this is were these
are night classes I had to have like all
badges to get in on the security and so
tonight
fantastic okay all right this is what
should be done okay people have to live
people have to have it you know you have
to have some way of supporting
themselves okay this is ridiculous like
graduating kids with it's crushing debts
and no what are we doing we're releasing
them into what they're going to be
working for McDonald's okay we should
thinks in terms of careers we should
think of how we are preparing people to
take to get jobs okay not just getting
jobs as the Ivy League does in in you
know in finance okay or in law okay and
you know the other you know this sort of
high hype the high tech you know high
ticket Mia professions and so on no okay
yeah right now it is expected that you
go to college why okay my my generation
the baby Mormons were the first where if
people are talking about the colleges oh
is a right they used to be very few
people when they catch my father was the
first member of his family to go to
college he would did on the GI Bill so
uh and I'm in the direct beneficiary you
know of it but that's all I did the
abandonment of the core curriculum okay
for this cafeteria-style you know way of
education today where people are just
picking out these likes crazy name but
it's not really true I mean in the sense
of you know there's no question that
every virtually every undergraduate it
has a much more structured curriculum
now they don't have a lot of options
they're told you know you know if you if
you talk to a typical English major they
have many more required courses if you
talk to for just general ed requirements
there are many more required courses
than there were in the seventies
honestly you're able to graduate okay
with degrees and literature without
having read in you know some several of
the major you know your authors I just
don't think that's true this the survey
courses are gone okay they're very four
places that have the survey courses any
longer like where you would have an art
history course that went to semesters
starting with with kvar and ending up
with it you know abstract modernism and
so on those have been abandoned okay
it's and these are some of the best
courses that were ever offered in the
American University with it with this
great vision of things a moving
chronological
over time showing influence and so on
okay they're been abandoned talk a
little bit about salon I mean this is
kind of fascinating you and you know
we're 20 years on from the beginning of
salon essentially you know you you were
writing for salon at a time when people
like David Horowitz the you know the
left-wing turned right winger was there
I mean it was a much more kind of
ecumenical place I mean the idea was
that people should be interesting now
we've hardened into you know what might
be called the politics of exclusion and
exhaustion where it's like you're either
a right winger or you're a left winger
your weekly standard neocon or you're a
salon you know PC warrior what is
driving that kind of intensification of
difference and of failure you know an
unwillingness to kind of Brook any sort
of overlap between these guys I want to
say about salon is that is that salon in
this great period was that you still had
a David Talbott the convener the main
founder of in charge okay and David
Talbots mind is very very sophisticated
too cosmopolitan okay and he was he was
interested in the full range of ideas he
had tremendous pressures this was this
is a great editor a certain point he
retired from direct management of the
magazine David Talbots an imprint on
salon gradually faded and it became in
in what what happened was today's salon
is some it's like a collegiate magazine
to me okay the the the headlines are
strident you know the it's like
knee-jerk predictable okay and I think
it's very very sad I think it's one of
the most tragic declines in the history
of the contemporary media okay is what's
happened to salon what do you think more
broadly about kind of ideologies you
know they're I mean in the 21st century
largest in the 15 years that we've had
does does libertarianism is that a kind
of political or ideological position
that actually can give off or something
good to the future well it appears that
you know the Rand Paul has been moving
you know drawing a excited kind of
college crowd it'll be interesting to
see whether whether the young people a
you know
and have the kind of old-style
sense of identification with
democratic-republican I have I have the
sense it's not entirely comfortable
sense okay that you know that my
students have slowly morphed away from
even paying attention to politics over
the past let's say 15 years and it's
worried me because because of the crises
around the world are actually
intensifying and how are they you know
how are they going to cope as a
generation well and to go back to I mean
you as mention that you're a Democrat I
assume you're your parents for Democrats
no but you have an Intel gram loyal my
grandfather's generation where Democrats
my grandfather was a worked in the
factory Endicott Johnson shoe factory
and they loved Roosevelt and so on okay
and then that generation my parents
generation it turned into kind of the
shifted during the disorders of the
1960s and there was a shift toward the
Republican right in the 70s and so on
and I've always been a Democrat myself
okay but you know I know and I voted for
Obama I remain a registered Democrat but
I voted green okay in the light in the
last for the second you know actually I
voted for a woman president alrighty
Jill Stein okay and so on and I continue
to I die - can you send money to the
green party even though people might
think okay then I since I'm the skeptic
about global warming and so that what am
i doing but I honestly still believe
that the Green Party is closer to the
vision of the 1960s that I remember then
what the Democratic Party has become
okay what you know when you're talking
about students now is it a bad thing
that they are you know they're like I
forget politics I mean because there was
a huge element of the 60s
revolution which was like you know what
politics that's old men you know duking
it out and try to make you know trying
to throw our bodies in front of each
other is it a bad thing I mean because
that's one of the the promises of
libertarianism really is that we squeeze
politics down to the smallest sphere
possible so we can get on with more
meaningful parts of our lives well I'm
just concerned if you're not interested
at all and what it would in the in the
news or in you know in political
sparring and maneuverings and so on then
how can you possibly have an
influence on you know on the future I'm
worried that we're heading toward a kind
of Big Brother Empire okay where you
where you have people you know the sort
of career politicians at the top in
league with with the public masters of
the media okay the ability to you know
to manage the news they it's the
complete drop of journalistic standards
now that the newspapers are like
vanishing I'm a no young person reads a
newspaper okay that's not the way I so
that without without staff you know of
investigative reporters how are you ever
going to be able to get you know
in-depth stories that might take a year
to research you know so where it
appeared now instant but the people who
are reporting the news and writing the
news don't even bother to say they'll
just report what a government official
is as if it's the truth you don't even
have to have you know a disclaimer like
but such as an official claimed okay you
just have total is it whatever you know
from the media's acting as a total
mouthpiece okay that's and that bothered
me during the run-up to the Iraq war I
was like the only person was who spoke
out in salon at length ok against the
Iraq war everyone fell down a flat in
front in front of what the government
was saying how much of this is that your
reading habits are attuned to previous
eras so that you know you have groups
like Pro Publica you have the Marshall
Foundation which is headed up by former
New York Times editor you know that
looks at sentencing reform and is doing
long-form criminal justice I mean is how
much I mean because you know you're so
relentlessly negative we are saying has
nothing to do whatever okay with the
main with the main forum okay of the
news okay I am constantly monitoring the
main forum of things you know I try to
start with something that's that's in
the news and I'm able to monitor how
aware might the students are okay and
I'm telling you over the last 15 years
step by step by step okay there is
getting worse and worse and worse
what do you know if I were at Yale or
you know or at Harvard I'm sure the
pre-law students are constantly
monitoring the news and they would know
exactly what what I'm talking about
okay and you would hate them for the way
yeah yeah yeah the arts and communicate
this is the future of art they
communicate
here okay all right right that's the
feature blog and so and so but you know
I because I'm thinking of like during my
tenure at reason and I started in 93
it's I I know that our venue
you know our audience has grown our
influence you know people at the
Washington Post call us up people at NPR
people you know so in that main form it
seems that alternative news sources
which do long-form reporting you know
there were actually growing in terms of
our influence not not necessarily in you
know in every issue you know on every
issue and there is in many ways you know
when you look at the transformations and
things like gay men or marriage equality
pot legalization
skepticism about war it seems like you
know you're right certainly before the
Iraq war there was nothing from the
mainstream media but now people you know
there seems to be a skepticism forming
which has to be coming from somewhere
hey okay okay I can say is all right you
know when you know when the Hillary and
and her you know Valkyrie warriors like
you know God got us into Libya I would
then I didn't notice okay anything okay
I was up absolutely no hope I which I
couldn't begin my salon column and
condemned that okay because here's the
end result
okay the total stabilization of Libya
okay so I know it wasn't a please there
was nothing okay everyone one fell down
flat in front of that one too yeah I
think what the libertarianism needs is a
strong candidate Rand Paul is just not
taking seriously okay if he really wants
to run for president he's just not
taking anything seriously I mean the
presidency is not it's not just a post
of power and also a symbolic okay and
you have to look a certain way and you
have to act a certain way you know
whether it's a democrat or republican
what should a candidate look like
whether it's male or female
well yeah I did the huge impact on me
was when I was 13 okay when John F
Kennedy was running okay so I mean I
don't went on a campaign from I went
downtown I awake black in the Sun
support and in this you can't imagine
what it was like coming out of the of
this sleepy Eisenhower years okay with
Mamie Eisenhower on the White House and
so on we didn't we didn't know why
Eisenhower was a great war hero we don't
I think of that okay and this incredibly
charismatic man okay would then
accomplish nothing
for us okay but but this whole ability
to speak I mean when you look back you
know it
I mean that for a while been
disillusioned you know with JFK but when
I've looked back at some you know some
documentaries that show him speaking on
the road you know when he was
campaigning with he that was a smart guy
in fact his management of press
conferences was was internal course he
created the genre but a Wow he was like
pinpoint and sharp and he just puts
everyone else's shame with their managed
questions and their plan but you know
call list you know a list of people
etcetera etcetera okay so like a sense
of sprezzatura is important what else
goes into the perfect one he had been in
the military he had been the name okay
so the point is that so that's another
thing that's a problem now okay without
with with with with contemporary
politics is that in America the whole
generation of men that had experience in
the war the realities of war and had
been abroad you know had experienced the
horrors and so on it's going and so we
have all these guys who are products of
Ivy League schools and it's Harvard and
Yale concentration of stuff it is this
is not good okay whereas in England
there's a tradition of course of the
upper class including the royal family
going into uniform okay so the sense of
commitment okay the ruling class has a
sense about war okay and in military
history and of sacrifice and so on now
we have an entire country of the
governing class has no we look at it
with this professional army and so this
that you know so that's the you know the
sufferings and the losses okay in are
being sucked on to others and this is
very dangerous to me
because because war is your encounter
with historical reality and with
elemental realities of life and death
okay so that to me is the explanation of
the problem also with it with the left
okay is that you know that because of
the transformation the slow change into
this a middle class culture that we
inhabit now the shrinking of the
industrial base okay the migration of
you know factors overseas what is meant
is that leftism has become totally
armchair rhetoric away with no direct
contact with real working-class people
okay now that is it a bad thing if we
don't have working-class peasant I think
that's it gives me okay now you know
there's a sense of grounding because my
you didn't work in a factory like my
grandfather my grandparents generation
all four all four grandparents were born
in Italy
and the in the countryside they were
farmers okay all right
my mother was born there too okay they
came over here one grandfather worked in
the shoe factory okay and I was like
living in their Hall but but you're very
riding you're free riding on you know my
father was yeah I mean all of our
parents were you know factory this is
the difference okay okay to meet in them
in the leftist that I know in a khadeem
they did not have this experience they
have never had any direct experience of
working-class life most of them almost
overwhelming but if the leftist of the
60s did okay
their parents okay with this like mine
okay they had to had experiences social
mobility okay so Mike we know was all of
a sudden okay you know I was born with
my pet my father was in college okay so
and I lived in this factory towns my for
my first home okay
my grandfather came back from the
factory every day that the factories
dominate for Andy Warhol so that's very
similar thing in Pittsburgh okay and so
on and so you get this populist feeling
okay you know when you emerge from that
and my father became a high school
teacher and eventually he became a
college professor was long afterwards
I'd have a television or tea you know or
achieve our telephone until I was 12
okay so for having six we don't have any
money okay so the point is this gives
you reality it gives you a sense of
practicality I'm like with I'm just one
generation removed from the farmland
okay and cetera right and this is the
what's missing there's this the
middle-class academic you know a leftist
yeah you know and all these people they
know nothing actually okay but they have
this distant sense of the working-class
very condescending okay about working
that you're from here and they are
somehow empowered they are destined to
help okay from the from the point of
view of an intrusion of state authority
given this vast complex you know this
this octopus of state authority that's
going to help me other poor people so it
does does something it does a similar
dynamic work or how does that work on
the right or do you or you're not that
interested in it because you're coming
out of a lot I feel there has definitely
been a kind of a fossilization okay of
authentic analysis the kind of joy being
joking snide thing about Obama so I mean
I hated that about Bush I hated about a
viola okay this thing about this is the
president okay I he should be I don't
care what errors they make and
ultimate adventure huge errors the depth
you know the position of president
should be treated with some dignity this
is degradation you know of prestige of
our of our you know institutions it's
like it's very bad okay the cynicism the
snarkiness when you're from the 1960s
and you're you're upset at the you know
people taking potshots at instance no no
no I believe we should attack you attack
you criticize you don't demean okay III
don't I don't need a snit no I mean I
mean I if it tease me to read okay and I
love to read the commenters yeah because
I think it's a whole new genre now and
in the end though in the you know the
jokes with Obama's name Oh bummer and
this is mando bamming and or Romney as
mitten so you know and all this stuff
coming that's coming from you know from
the from the Tea Party and so on well by
the way I wish I respect the Tea Party I
don't I don't I don't I don't demonize
them but no there's a way of just like
snide way now I enjoy anti-hillary and
you know to the jobs I think that's a
whole art okay to culture what what is
it about is Hillary Clinton kind of your
worst nightmare as a water she's exactly
my age yeah okay I feel I know her
completely okay she hurt hurt hurt you
know she has some Scranton in the
background and so on in fact we are
accents almost kind of kind of the same
and so on I understand her completely
okay alright so I see all the you know
the games and the in the you know the
falsehoods and so on so forth so I I've
enjoyed I made a career practically out
of life a guy wrote a what the cover
story for the New Republic was what was
the ice queen drag queen that was like
maybe six anyway I was like way back
Larissa so what is about Hillary that
bothered explain to how is she a frog if
what she can't can't have an opinion
without
poll testing it and so on right she's a
liar okay she you know she has this is
not a strong candidate for president for
our first woman president to be Dianne
Feinstein presenter so you could no I
don't care what I don't care what okay I
don't care what her views are okay what
I'm saying is to for the post of
president that's commander in chief gave
the military it's got to be a woman okay
who has a familiarity with military
matters
okay and also has gravitas yeah talk a
little bit about this when feinstein at
you know i first became aware of her
okay after that those murders that
occurred okay in city hall she certainly
never let you forget that she was there
no but i have never forgotten because
was one the great moments a woman took
charge okay i'm a nap scene of absolute
chaos okay in Barbara's murder okay
alright and hold in the whole government
was like falling apart and she came to
the media and gave the news okay and it
was steady and I said that's it okay
that's the formula I think for the first
woman president it's my duty to make
this announcement both mayor Moscone and
supervisor Harvey Milk have been shot
and killed the
Oh
why
the suspect is supervisor Dan White how
do you communicate how to use the media
to communicate okay so up to for a woman
must communicate she's gonna be the one
president she was community both
strength and reserve and yet compassion
okay what's that formula and I've been
waiting and waiting and waiting for the
formula the only one who's had it in
America's for some concern was I in
Feinstein okay all right and she didn't
put it up forward for whatever reason
okay as president but Hillary does not
have it okay Hillary is a mess okay it
we're good we're going to reward with
the presidency a woman who has enabled
him you know depredations and the
Indiana and the exploitation of women
okay by that by that you know didn't
find them you know cornpone husband
first and so on I mean he said that the
wave feminism feminism medicines blind
okay to to Hillary's record okay you
know of thrashing if they were going to
try to destroy Monica Lewinsky so um I
mean it's a scandal anyone who believes
in sexual harassment guidelines okay
should have seen that the disparity of
power we doin Clinton in Monica Lewinsky
was once the most grotesque ever looking
in the history of sex crime he's a sex
criminal again so um oh we're gonna put
that guy back in the White House okay
she this was Hillary's ridden on his
coattails yeah she's not a woman who has
her own career federal career cheeky
jomo found the bar exam in Washington
okay I should put in dollars we should
she went to Arkansas okay got a job in
the Rose law firm with you because her
husband was yeah alright let's uh
because I'm an optimistic person and
this is an optimistic country can you
say something what what are you excited
about we're optimistic about in this
twilight of the American Century what am
i optimistic about um is there any
reason for us to you know to be getting
up other than to fight an existential
battle against darkness well we're so
isolated here in the United States
geographically you know that's yeah we
don't have to worry about the Japanese
bombing up again those that wherever it
is they're like what's good it's
anything good in your life in our world
I know but you know I
I enjoy living in America I would cook
over little America okay because I feel
then you can you can accept in academia
you can do whatever you want okay yeah
and and it I think it's still a very
fertile area for entrepreneurship I
think you know people with with new
ideas okay can come out of nowhere okay
and become millionaires overnight in
some of our most interesting people
successful people we did not graduate
from college and can everyone from you
know it's a Matt Drudge didn't go to
calories and you know mama yeah and so
on
look ruling though you know in the world
of media that jobs I mean if there's so
many examples of it's right but I I just
want you know I'm an educator okay so I
want the reform of Education okay and I
and I just feel that there should be no
more vocational training at the high
school level to offer jobs you know
training in the trades okay for for
people in the inner city okay who like
into directing people to them toward
college makes absolutely no sense
considering that other dilution of the
current college curriculum I don't see
what the point what the point of that is
unless someone already is showing talent
or in or interest in going into law or
medicine or something like that
you know it's alright I mention that
okay in you know and by the public
primary school education it's an
absolute cash right now
absolute hash I can see what the
students don't know when they arrive you
know in college okay I mean they're the
people who are teaching at Harvard and
Yale are getting the products of private
schools and all kinds of private
tutoring and so on they're not they are
not in tune with what's happening in the
culture I believe I am because because
the students have come to this art
school are from every possible social
level okay they're they're very talented
working-class you know jazz musicians
and dancers okay that I get in the
classroom I have you know occasionally
you know I'll get there might be a
student from a private school every like
five years but mostly they're good
suburban schools whether you know less
good so I know what they what they're
getting in the you know in their in
school and it's basically zero okay what
they're getting is they're get you're
being taught don't bully okay alright
you know like everyone can negotiate and
compromise and so on they have no
they've never been taught geography they
don't know world geography okay so on
all right
they know nothing about history
okay so what are you optimistic about
America it's like it to me okay full of
fresh and you know creative energy
showcase on that it worry we're being
saddled by the competent you know
government that sort of sapping you know
sapping you know I think I look less you
think about the government maybe that
maybe maybe they maybe the better I know
I I still feel you know I wouldn't live
anywhere else but but the United States
okay I'd or that using nature I my
current project by the way is about Nate
Native American Inc paleo-indian culture
okay that's right that's where I am in
my mind right now
okay and let's end with that what is so
what are you working on a most I'm
working on I'm interested in okay the
the actual Native American history the
predates all this ideological right you
know warfare over genocide and so on
okay I'm talking about the period after
it was as the glaciers withdrew from the
United States okay the paleo-indian
period which is like you know 10,000 to
15,000 BC I'm talking I'm talking about
I'm very interested in the the world
view the metaphysic the religion of that
period and I think I have some instinct
for it because of my interest in history
of religion and I'm very interested in
religion as an atheist
okay I I that's what one of one of my
ambitions okay is to restore the
prestige of religion okay to just
secular humanism which I think it's
gotten very cynical and it's gotten less
and less creative you know the lesson
thinks about religion well we'll leave
it there thank you so much Camille Poway
thank you it has been a wonderful
conversation for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie
you